because I believe that it's the right
thing for the country and you know
without sounding too pious about it I
actually think at the end of the day the
the motivation why most people go and
should go into politics is because they
want to do what's right for the country
they love and I really do worry that all
the other alternatives now since no
one's going to win an outright majority
in other words the prospect of a lurch
to the left and excessive reckless
borrowing a Zeb Miliband has to dance to
the tune of of Alex Salmond or alert the
writers David Cameron has to dance the
tune of his own right wing and impose
ever more ideological cuts on public
services I really worry about those
alternatives and what what it will do to
our country and that's why I think we
need to remain anchored in the center
ground act responsibly and fairly and
provide stability which is incredibly
important particularly given the
fragility of the of the economic
recovery and I think that can only be
done with liberal democrats back in
government in sizable numbers ever there
are two problems with that one is that
that's not what it appears the public
want according to just about every
opinion pulses 2010 and the other
problem of course is you are a party
leader you appear to be saying you'd be
prepared to sacrifice your party in the
service of the government no but on the
latter point there's not much point
going to politics unless you're prepared
to do your duty by the country unless
you're prepared to do what you think is
right even in difficult circumstances
unless you're prepared to step up to the
plate when it's right for the country
when you're prepared to actually stick
with it despite all the pressures to do
otherwise when you're prepared to hold
firm when others might buckle and the
Liberal Democrats have done that over
the last five years and of course that
has has led to a sore dent in our short
term popularity but i tell you i'd much
rather that than the Liberal Democrats
having sort of just sort of standing
back and wiping our hands clean of any
responsibility for the affairs of the
nation and seeing unemployment going up
interest rates going up the cost of
living going up I don't I wouldn't want
that on my conscience and neither would
any liberal Democrat right you said uh
giving a campaign you weren't going to
start negotiating and laying down red
lines but subsequently the last few days
you've done that well you like the other
leaders making last-minute announcements
could you just remind us what your
conditions are for working first of all
going back into coalition with David
Cameron
yes I'm just on the first point we've
always been very clear about what the
priorities are we put them on the front
page of our manifesto balancing the
books and doing so fairly making sure
that people don't pay any income tax on
the first 12 and a half thousand pounds
that they and putting the money into the
NHS that it needs and valuing mental
health on the same footing as physical
health protecting spending in in
education and making sure that our
qualified teachers in all classrooms and
protects I okay and just like you'll
remember from your Haina but just it
comes to your point and the reason why
I've sort of if you like gonna step
further and announced this week that we
will not enter into a coalition unless
education spending is properly protected
from the cuts that both labor and the
Conservatives have protect our planning
the reason I've said that we won't enter
into a coalition unless there is an
early stability budget to make sure the
country and the markets and investors
know that we have a plan to balance the
books and do so fairly the reason I've
said that those are red lines for us and
I'm making further announcements during
the course of this week on on any
additional red lines is because I think
given the very fraction fragmented
nature of politics given the very
uncertain outcome of the election given
the threat of uncertainty to our
economic recovery it's important that
people are crystal clear about what they
will get come hell or high water if they
vote for Liberal Democrats yep you see
that's where it gets complicated because
let's take your pledge today to extend
free school meals to all primary
children not just those are the infant
levels you say you do that when the
books are balanced in 2017 2018 but as I
understand it with labor you're not
demanding that they balance the books by
then so therefore if there was a lab lib
pact that promised is worthless well as
it happens I haven't said it's a red
line I'm being of course because I
totally accept if you just draw red
lines everywhere they were one just is a
great big standoff and nothing happens
I'm being responsible and and it's just
it doesn't mean it was a headline
grabber no no no actually as you might
remember 75% of the Liberal Democrat
manifesto in 2010 in addition to all the
front page priorities and made their way
into the coalition agreement in fact the
Liberal Democrats have punched way above
our weight I lead a party of eight
percent of MPs in Western
and yet we had more of our manifesto in
the coalition agreement than the larger
party in the coalition the Conservatives
did and I would be determined to do that
again and I challenge anybody to explain
why it's a bad idea to extend the
provision of free school meals to
children across the across all primary
school free school meals is not included
in your ring fence around education
spending you know what I've said exactly
what I said very carefully is that I
think it is essential that we provide
money for nursery schools and colleges
which keeps up not only with the
increase in prices inflation but also
the increase of numbers of kids going
into schools now labour want to cut by
but annually by the end of the next
parliament the money going into
education by two and a half billion
pounds and the Conservatives even more
draconian want to cut by five billion
pounds that is simply unfair on the next
generation and I will not see the next
generation being short changed by those
labour and conservative cuts on
nurseries and schools and colleges
across the country and you wouldn't
presumably match the pledge which David
Cameron's given today on dat national
insurance and income tax levels I mean
you you would see some room for some of
those to go up well it's just it's just
I just think I said I think it's such a
bizarre stopped I mean if he you know
David Cameron trusts what a conservative
Chancellor were to do why on earth is
you need to pass a law change shows a
high level so a lack of self-confidence
at the Conservative Party that they have
to pass a law that they say they would
do if they want to at a majority very
peculiar really unsettling sit and
Senate instead of having these stunts I
think what they should be doing is
instead of sort of giving with one hand
with all these unfunded tax buttons and
then taking with both hands they should
become clear with the British public
before next Thursday on the level of the
ideological cuts they want to impose on
education the level of cuts they want to
impose on people who receive help
through the welfare system who are down
on their luck that's where the
Conservative Party needs to be more
clear so what are your red lines for a
coalition with labour my red lines are
the red lines for whoever wants to speak
to the Liberal Democrat liberal
democrats and I've already set out one
sorry I've set up one on Monday which
was that we're not going to abide by the
cuts that labor in the Conservatives
want to impose an education
then i set out that we would insist on a
stability budget within 50 days of a of
a new Parliament being formed so that we
create stability in the economy don't
jeopardize the economic recovery and set
out a plan by which we balance the books
and do so fairly and I'm setting out
further red lines over the coming days
so that people have a very very clear
clear view you also said you'd have no
truck with deals with you Kip and the
SNP now you cannot not like to have that
many MPs the SNP may well have more MPs
than you do they've said they wouldn't
vote for the Tories but you might
require them to vote for a Labour lib
packed in effectively in Parliament
would that be okay with you if they
weren't just part of the deal but they
made it clear that they would support
that I honestly all these end I think we
starting to dance on the head of a pin
with all these nykkus think you wouldn't
do feels like yes okay I'm asking you
what you meant I'm telling you I meant
it's very simple principle which is in
the same way that I wouldn't put Nigel
Farage in charge of a Union the European
Union that he wants to sort of pull
apart I simply don't understand why on
earth anyone would put a party that
whose sole objective in life is to pull
the united kingdom apart in charge of
the government of the United Kingdom
it's it's really not not any more
complicated than that and that's why the
Liberal Democrats won't enter into a
little deal or arrangement with the SMP
and I think a government which which is
on life support system where Alex salmon
and Nicola Sturgeon comes to pull the
plug at any moment in exactly the same
way that a right-wing alliance in which
it's the right wing of the Conservative
Party Nigel Farage the DP and others who
can basically pull the plug on the
Conservative Party I I think that is
just a really bad outcome for the United
Kingdom because it guarantees
instability populism and factions ok
let's get this absolutely clear then
what you're saying is you would not form
a minority coalition with labor because
inevitably the SMP would hold the
bouncer par in that situation is so it's
only if you've got more than a majority
between you that you would consider a
formal coalition with labour is that
right it's what I said I can only repeat
myself the global Democrats will not
enter into a government which is
basically in existence at the say-so of
either you kippur the
SMP I got two questions for you then one
is on the very point you're just raising
their whatever the result of this
election how much work do you think
needs to be done now to repair the UK
Constitution given that the Scottish
people clearly seem to be about to
express a fairly radical view of the
future of the Union yeah knowing is a
really good question and actually many
respects partly because it's quite a
sort of can be subtle arcane debate it
hasn't assumed nearly enough importance
in this election campaign but my own
view is that almost whatever the outcome
of the election next Thursday we are
going to enter into a significant period
of constitutional change and reform and
renewal that's an opportunity and that's
why I've always advocated a all party
constitutional convention so that we can
get together involving people for
outside politics not just politicians
citizens panel and so on can be involved
so that we can have a really good head
to toe look at the imbalances and flaws
in the British constitution because the
tectonic plates as you say are shifting
within the United Kingdom I try to
persuade David Cameron months ago now in
the wake of the Scottish referendum in
fact even before it that we should
announce as a government coalition
government that all party constitutional
convention but you know that the
Conservatives are not particularly
interested in wholesale constitutional
reform only in base of the bitty
piecemeal reform but it has to be done
then it has to be done if possible on a
cross-party basis and the sooner we can
start an all-party cross oh sorry a
cross-party constitutional convention
with participation of the public after
may the seventh the better and just
finally would the lib dems be doing
better if Miriam was in charge haha i
think the nation on the world would be
doing better if mirror was in charge
that's my general rule in life let's
collect thank you for joining us